so the district attorney bruce castor  decided to issue  a promise to cosby that they weren't  going to go forward with prosecuting him  and  there's some controversy here as to  whether there is an agreement or not  cosby waived his fifth amendment rights  against self-incrimination and gave  four depositions in the civil case that  constant brought against him the idea is  that if the prosecutors weren't going to  be able to criminally prosecute cosby  at least the victim could recover civil  damages which she was able to do she won  millions of dollars  and even in the civil case cosby could  have exercised his fifth amendment right  not to incriminate himself but he  decided to give the depositions the  depositions included all kinds of  inculpatory  statements including the fact that he  gave quaaludes to women and then had sex  with them but that's only half the story